ladies and mmm the mics not working  via diary is sort of a funny story  but I can't go back and keep making same  mistakes  when I can make new ones  going mad  [Music]  is that your most serious curtains do  you like it you can have a genuinely  good spot I'm actually with the Mexican  ambassador the head of Amnesty  International and the undersecretary for  Trade and Industry right  we belong together James is there  someone here  but if staying here meets working within  10 yards of you frankly I'd rather have  a job wiping Saddam Hussein's ass I love  you I always have and I always will  a few months ago I met Janet  and then the next week I'm pregnant  [Music]  so you have no idea which of us is the  father surely one of those days more  likely they're both equally likely so do  bring along the father if you can work  out which one he is  baby love with him I have been in me I  could be and they the most important  thing is the baby the best thing I've  ever seen  [Music]  you